فماذا لو قلنا لك أن هناك طرقًا
لإطالة عمرك ليس فقط ببضع
سنوات إلى ما يصل إلى 24 عامًا؟ ماذا لو قلنا
لك أيضًا أن ذلك سيتطلب
اختيارات بسيطة جدًا لأسلوب الحياة، هل
ستكون جميعًا في صحة جيدة، دراسة جديدة  يقدم
دليلاً على أن مفاتيح
حياة أطول تحدث فرقًا من خلال بعض
العادات الصحية البسيطة جدًا.
مراسلة الصحة في CNN جاكلين هوارد
هنا مع التفاصيل وجاكلين
ليست المرة الأولى التي نسمع فيها أنك تقوم بإجراء
بعض التغييرات هنا وهناك، لا أفعل ذلك.  لا
أعرف تناول كميات أقل من الدهون والمشي مرة واحدة يوميًا، كما
تعلم أنه بمرور الوقت سيزداد عدد السكان بشكل
طفيف، لكن 24 عامًا،
وهذا كذب كثيرًا، كما تعلم أن هذا
وقت طويل، لذا أخبرنا بما يقولونه
لنا للقيام
بذلك  قد تبدو هذه العادات الثمانية
واضحة للبعض ولكن من المثير للاهتمام
رؤيتها مرتبة حسب العادات
التي لها أكبر ارتباط
بالعيش لفترة أطول، لذلك نبدأ بالمركز
الأول في ممارسة التمارين الرياضية بانتظام،
والمركز الثاني بعدم إساءة استخدام المواد الأفيونية،
والمركز الثالث بعدم  تم العثور على أن تدخين تلك الثلاثة الأوائل
له أكبر
ارتباط بطول العمر، ثم نرى
ذلك يتبعه إدارة التوتر لديك، واتباع
نظام غذائي صحي، وعدم الإفراط في شرب الخمر،
والحصول على قسط كافٍ من النوم، وإقامة
علاقات اجتماعية إيجابية، لذلك
ارتبطت جميع هذه العادات الثمانية في صالة الألعاب الرياضية
وفقًا لـ  هذا البحث الجديد الذي تم
تقديمه اليوم فقط كان
مرتبطًا بإضافة ما يصل إلى 24 عامًا إلى
متوسط ​​العمر المتوقع، لذا فإن هذه
العادات الثمانية جيم، من المثير للاهتمام رؤية
المواد الأفيونية في تلك القائمة لأنه من الواضح
أننا رأينا أن لها
تأثيرًا كبيرًا على متوسط ​​العمر المتوقع في  هذا
البلد،
فماذا عن الناس، ولن
أخبرك لماذا أسألك،
هذا بالتأكيد لن يتعلق
بوضعي الخاص، ولكن ماذا عن الأشخاص الذين يبدأون
هذه العادات الصحية الجديدة في وقت لاحق من
حياتهم، هل هذا ما زال يصنع
فرق، وهل يمكن أن يحدث هذا
الفارق لعدة سنوات؟
في هذه الدراسة،
وجد الباحثون أن أولئك الذين بدأوا هذه
العادات الصحية في منتصف العمر ما زالوا يرون
الفوائد الصحية، لذلك لم يفت الأوان بعد
لبدء جيم في العيش بأسلوب حياة صحي.